the jurgen experience well that's
one of the problems with some ideas that
promote
air quotes feminism is that they treat
women
as if they they can't see things the way
that men do so they need
extra attention extra help or extra
assistance my favorite one with like
that kind of like
navel gazing critical approach so
let me preface just because we have to
in this day and age james do you support
feminism
which one same as black lives matter
right which one do you mean so that said
um one of my favorite patterns is is a
thing happens to everybody and then
feminists think it's oppression against
women feminist playing patriarchy
so it's like you know people interrupt
and it's like
people interrupt women and so that's
patriarchy and it's like it actually
happens to everybody man
my favorite is mansplaining mansplaining
oh yeah we're doing that now
my favorite is man spreading as you all
know famously
a man spreader and i have my profile on
twitter is
is man spreading to the maximum is that
what you're doing in your profile
oh yeah it's actually funny i was doing
the thing in london last
october we were doing some talks and i
was actually explaining i had
one video i did where i didn't even
realize that i was man spreading like
out of control i mean it was like
embarrassingly bad i looked at it the
first time i saw a video right but man
spreading only matters if you're on a
subway
or a bus and someone's next to you and
you're that's the main
but that's what the problem is with it
right but they see the action at all
like you gotta train it out of people
so anyway in london i was very i was
actually distractedly mindful not to
manspread instead i was telling the
story to the crowd and i manspread
to demonstrate what i meant by manspring
i just did it again and
somebody snapped a picture of it while i
was doing it and sent it to me and i'm
like
that's my profile picture so i'm liking
you know like a jacket and a tie
and i'm man spreading like laughing or
whatever i feel like i read this i don't
know if i did or not
um that men their natural
the way their their legs sit in their
hips it's natural for their legs to
splay out
yeah whereas with women their hips are
built differently
that's probably true well can you find
that out we also have
i don't know which how you would google
that yeah but i mean i think you do i
know i do
okay definitely do just how dare you um
but you can't
i'd rather stand up i mean if i'm
jamming people
in like that i don't mind standing yeah
totally i hear you yeah
unless unless it's a long ass flight but
or a long
ass um uh train ride but i can keep my
legs together no i hear you
i'm totally with you but i think it's a
natural thing i think
it makes sense spread out and like i
mean you're fit i'm fit i actually have
bizarrely large legs and so it's
actually very difficult for me to
squeeze my legs here it goes
the overall width of the pelvis is
relatively greater in females and the
angle of the femoral neck
is more acute that's right these factors
could play a role in making a position
of sitting with the knees close together
less comfortable in men aha you
i suspect most men would suggest the
reason for adopting the more spread
posture
in sitting would be the avoidance of
testicular compression
from the thigh muscles the pelvic
rotation
goes some way to improve compression in
both aspects
it's funny the way they say it that way
that's right they have to say testicular
compression that's because it's from
masculine
science it's masculinist white western
science making this claim
and it's from the independent okay yeah
but when you have big legs man
it's like yes it's like you know if i
know i'm gonna have to walk a long
distance i have to wear
the right underwear i'm gonna get
chaffed on my thighs yes these big
thighs
so there's a problem behind man's it's
like i need those like uh
chuck norris drop crotch jeans that he
had those when he used his kicks
two those do you remember those i had a
pair of those hell yeah chuck norris
action jeans action jeans that's right
yes i had those that's right back when
were you doing karate you know you're
doing taekwondo right
yeah i did i did like sport karate back
then so yeah those were those that were
the pants to have
that's right everybody everybody had
that stuff
yeah those um the people with large
thighs man that's what boxer briefs were
invented for that's right
i can't wear uh regular shorts like if i
just wear shorts and boxer briefs
it'll chew my legs up that's right if i
work out it kills me yeah yeah and large
ladies have that issue too
right if they're overweight and fat
studies would say that that is a problem
of body blueprinting and
it's actually a sign that fat phobic
society hasn't designed all clothing
around
that problem they didn't design clothing
with fabulous in mind